bonsoir keumayou merci d'être avec nous
en direct de niamey avant d'évoquer
l'élection en elle-même un mot justement
sur ces sept agents électoraux de la
commission électorale nationale
indépendante qui en trouvé la mort dans
l'explosion de leur véhicule dans le sud
ouest donc du niger proche du mali
qu'est-ce que cela dit cela dit que nous
sommes dans un pays où le risque zéro
n'a pas été gardé je pense qu'il n'y a
aucun pays l'onu dans le monde qui peut
dire qu'il est à l'abri d'une attaque
terroriste de cette nature là puisqu'il
s'agit d'un engin explosif improvisé
déposer des artisans et c'est un ace sur
lequel il est difficile de d'exercer un
contrôle régulier
les autorités ont probablement déployé
eu tout ce qu'il fallait pour protéger
les populations qui se rendaient aux
élections mais quand on pose un engin
comme celui là cela peut se faire à
n'est que quelques mois dax qui est très
implanté il ya de nombreuses voitures
qui sont passés avant d'autres qui sont
passés après ce véhicule l'assaut des
faut dire que c'est une tête contre le
point démocratique mais que la réaction
devrait être de la part du niger de
montrer que sa démocratie ne dépend pas
d'eux des attaques terroristes et que
l'élection permettra de renforcer à la
fois la démocratie mais surtout les
institutions car ne cette démocratie là
puisqu'on a quand même un pays où le
président aurait pu modifier la
constitution pour se présenter une
troisième fois ils ne l'appellent a
passé la main en dauphin et 10e il est
fort possible que ce dauphin l'emportent
donc je pense que ce serait dommage que
l'on réduit cette élection aux accidents
qui ont été qui ont eu lieu en cours de
processus qui dit démocratie dit quand
même allés voter sereinement est ce que
c'est le cas est ce que les nigériens
ont pu voter
sereinement sa non venue il ya eu
quelques attaques qui il ya eu quatre
attaques à coffret qui on est et
berthomier des gens qui ont essayé de
prendre des deux urnes pour partir
d'autres qui ont essayé d'empêcher les
gens de se rendre dans les urnes en
faillite quelques camions et nous les
ont une mission d'observation électorale
tient une conférence de presse demain
c'est-à-dire ce mardi qu on aura
l'occasion d'en savoir un peu plus sur
tous ces faits qui ont été documentés et
sur lesquels ils exprimeront leur point
de vue en tant qu'observateur ce que
j'ai pu suivre mois à animer c'est que
les choses se sont passées tu as fait
enfin ordinaire mais vous savez que nous
sommes dans un pays qui est très grand
dont au moins le trois-quarts se trouve
tout près du désert du sahara et que
cette partie des territoires n'est pas
suffisamment contrôlé au nord justement
on à la libye qui a un état failli on a
à l'est la réunion de beauvoir et plus à
l'ouest
on a cette zone des trois frontières qui
concerne le niger le mali et le bol face
aux forces barca est censé apporter plus
de sécurité il ya eu une réunion
d'ailleurs avant le début de cette
élection qu'elle permit que le
contingent type siens soient remboursés
dans le dispositif sel
bon ce n'est pas suffisant pense qu'on
en a encore pour quelques années à
combattre le terrorisme dans le sahel et
plus précisément au niger alors parlons
de l'élection le camp du président
sortant
qu'ont présenté par mohamed bazoum est
sorti en tête de ce premier tour
largement et avec 39% des voix comment
vous analysé ce chiffre je pense que
c'est déjà nouvelle pour classer
nigérienne que les électeurs et deux
round d'élections prononcer plus jeunes
la personne qui va présider aux
destinées du pays
il ya eu beaucoup de coups cas comme on
les aime restait 2 par dès le premier
tour deux candidats qui étaient en place
c'est bien pour le jeu démocratique que
quillan peu de suspens et que au bout de
tours d'élection les citoyens le choix
des lags et parce que n'oublions pas
qu'il ya eu trente candidats lors du
premier tour et que dans le du tour il
choisit également le candidat sur lequel
ils estiment qu'ils ont des meilleurs
promettent par rapport à l'avenir du
pays ou sur lequel ils ont l'impression
que les engagements pris en termes de
programmes toro se pendent le plus à
leurs aspirations donc de mon point de
vue c'est une bonne chose qu'ils aient
eu deux tours et qu' aucun des candidats
n'est plus retenir avant ce deuxième
tour plus de 600 dhs et les exprime
alors clairement eric maillaud quels
sont les grands chantiers qui attendent
le futur président le niger pour cette
mandature
il y avait plusieurs le premier et le
plus important c'est déjà celui de la
sécurité
c'est de pouvoir et les nigériens le
fait que leur pays peut redevenir un
havre de paix le deuxième celui de la
spli des salines aussi parce que
n'oublions pas que le pays atteint et
frappé aussi par la crise sanitaire ou
dans des conditions il faudrait et les
mesures terre mais au delà des mesures
sanitaires se sont toutes les
conséquences les dommages collatéraux
ils seront produits par le confinement
et toutes les mesures barrières et à la
lutte contre la pauvreté 19
et puis à tous les chantiers urgents on
a entendu tout se dit ya eu sur la
qualité mohamed bazoum qui lui contester
parce qu'on estime qu'il est à ab qu'il
appartient à une minorité qui est très
faible et qui est originaire de la ville
dont je crois qu'il ya ceci si tu n'es
ce qu'il faut repenser d'urgence sociale
qu'il faut également remplir et puis il
ya tout le chantier de l'intégration
afrique
le chantier de mocratie le chantait de
l'éducation des jeunes de leur emploi
les chantiers se paie donc je pense
il n'y aura peut-être pas des tas de
passe mais il y aura surtout un besoin
pour le chef élu que dans man dans ses
habits et de retisser tout le lien
social qui a manqué de rassurer ses
compatriotes sur sécurité et le
développement
social merci louis keumayou président du
club de l'information africaine d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france